so let's talk politics because I know
you care about her yes I find it very
interesting that if Donald Donald Trump
is the nominee he will be the most
disliked nominee in history and Hillary
would be the second most disliked the
only nominee in either party who was
liked by more people than not than
disliked is Bernie Sanders I don't find
them unelectable I think that's
something I don't know what who's
perpetuating this on the radio thing
damn media the jew-run media he yeah
isn't it funny he's really popular Gary
with both sides everyone likes him and
he's not for sale not playing the game
and it says what he means and he you
know those YouTube videos of him on the
Senate floor you know questioning the
you know Obama's choice for the head of
the FDA or Alan Greenspan on the stuff
it's so kick-ass and what about the
civil rights video him and he was listen
he's been on the right side of history
at every turn not along with history not
when it becomes popular but before it's
popular war
why are my guy Hilary was my candidate I
like Hillary this isn't an anti anything
I just an alternative came along you
know all the baseball players used
steroids so then all the baseball
players use steroids so that's an even
so they can compete and that's how I
think of citizens united you know
Hillary takes money from banks and big
business and super PACs so did Barack
Obama she's no different than anybody
else she was the best choice I thought
considering they all do it then someone
came along who doesn't take steroids who
is not for sale the big the people that
inspire people and the people that uh
you know are you know Gandhi didn't have
a complex message it's pretty simple
it's just the honest truth
you know his concern isn't his coffers
it's not elections it's not whatever
it's just his is he is intended to no
one except for the American people
that's his thing no Bernie okay
so white why is he not catching on with
african-americans Bernie they're not
feeling the Bern I don't know do you
there's I think killer Mike is African
America that's one and that's when Spike
Lee is one I'm not gonna name it I just
feel it I just suddenly felt like I said
I have black friends
look I don't know okay just an actor I'm
not trying to be someone who's like all
into politics I grew up in New Hampshire
more political question talking I really
worked up all right Donald Trump Donald
Donald Trump said last week that he was
audited by the IRS possibly because of
my strong Christian faith why can't we
just give them their religious freedom
yes I know they're only 80 percent of
the country when you know that's such an
anti-semitic slate like everyone knows
Jews are auditors right
I'm glad you said it alright now I have
a question about Hillary for you and the
panel what seems like a big smart guy is
Bill Maher but if you just take a little
a